servus aus münchen das für nicht zu
vereinzelten der deg das einfach ja
immer wieder mitnehmen um die ecke kommt
ja ein bisschen aus einem gesunden
umfeld reißen dass wir gar nicht mal so
viele menschen sind das sind irgendwie
2000 aber wir haben einfach alle
unglaublich viel beizutragen dass es
gerade für journalisten natürlich wäre
spannend es gab einem sehr
faszinierenden vortrag in dem erzählt
wurde
wie weit die wissenschaft schon ist in
sachen gedanken lesen und das geht so
weit dass man diese gedanken sogar schon
zum teil verpflanzen kann
das hat man bei ratten gemacht man hat
der ein und hatte bei gebracht in dieser
ecke vom käfig ist strom drauf du
solltest du nicht hingehen und dann hat
man es geschafft diese erinnerung einer
anderen rasse einzupflanzen so dass die
andere ratte auch nicht in diese ecke
vom käfig gegangen ist und das ehrlich
gesagt ist schon ein bisschen unheimlich
gestern bei einem vortrag
da ging es um gehen veränderte menschen
und ich meine natürlich weiß man dass
diese technologien daher sind und dass
sie sich entwickeln aber wenn einem dann
so ein wissenschaftler wie denn die
messe des einem noch mal so vor augen
hält dass wir vielleicht irgendwann mal
designer babys haben dann schockiert ein
da ist ich habe am spannendsten in
welchen bereichen wir überall
verbesserungen von der quanten technik
zu erwarten haben chuck berry der der
quanten chef von google sozusagen ist
hat uns erzählt dass es eben nicht nur
im quantencomputer gehe die ganz krassen
schnell rechnen können sondern dass es
eben auch quanten sensoren gibt es
wesentlich günstiger machen ins gehirn
rhein gucken zu können das ganze
wesentlich auch exakt da machen können
dann habe ich die cambridge analytiker
whistleblowerinnen prothetik kaiser
getroffen
brittany war die zweite würde ich sagen
die wirklich erzählt hat was cambridge
politik hat mit der tram kampagne
gemeinsam gemacht hat wie sie
sehr genaue daten auf facebook gesammelt
haben und das genutzt haben für den
wahlkampf sie hat aber auch sonst eine
sehr spannende geschichte weil sie
eigentlich erst eine relativ linke
aktivistin war würde ich sagen sie hat
für die obama kampagne 2008 auch schon
im social media team gearbeitet und hat
praktisch die politische kommunikation
in den sozialen medien mit erfunden und
das hat sie dann genutzt um dabei zu
helfen an die macht zu kommen was aber
mindestens ebenso toll ist dass es jetzt
schneit und es ist das erste mal in
diesem jahr dass ich sehe dass es
irgendwo schneit und das finde ich
fantastisch